and speaking of Brett Cavanaugh's
confirmation hearing something
astonishing happened as they prepare to
break for lunch during yesterday's
hearing I want to bring the photo up on
your screen there is video but I want to
show the video for the the photo first
because the photo alone look at this you
can see the caliber of person that Brett
Kavanaugh is or rather isn't in this
case I mean just look at the smug
condescension in his eyes as this man
approaches him to shake his hand
the man reaching out to shake his hand
is Fred Guttenberg who is the father of
Jamie Guttenberg one of the many
students who was killed in parkland
Florida back on February 14th of this
year you know in the masker it was a
tragedy and he was introducing himself
to Greg Cavanaugh and you can see
Cavanaugh refused to shake his hand now
people are saying that oh well this
isn't what it looks like
you know conservatives are spending this
any kind of way they possibly can but
there's video take a look at this video
of just how much Cavanaugh thought about
it and then refused to shake this man's
hand
I mean you there's no way you could
spend this there's no absolutely no way
that you could spend this other than
Cavanaugh looked at Fred Guttenberg
calculated in his head had three seconds
there that I counted he calculated in
his head to listen to him he listened to
Fred as he introduced himself and said
my daughter was one of the ones killed
in parkland Florida and Cavanaugh turned
around and walked away now other people
are saying and actually I want to bring
up this tweet from Raj Shah who was the
deputy press secretary for Donald Trump
and I'll read it on your screen now he
said quote as Judge Kevin I'll let left
for his lunch break and unidentified an
individual approached him before the
judge was able to shake his hand
security had intervened really Raj I
mean there's video that all of us can
see right and you know and it's
worthwhile it's worthwhile to play the
video again let's play the video again
here so that you can see it yourself and
I'm going to narrate so that you
actually know no I'm not going to
narrate because I want you to see for
yourself at what point did security
intervene take a look
so as you could see security didn't
intervene until Brett Kavanaugh had
already turned around and began walking
away regardless how difficult is it for
you to show some decency and just some
empathy or just common courtesy right
you're on a national stage on a national
platform and you're trying to convince
America that you are the best pick for
the next cheetah for the next justice on
the Supreme Court that's what you're
trying to do and instead of calculating
that maybe I should just shake this
man's hand there's nothing there's
nothing hard about shaking someone's
hand especially when I'm in the
limelight for brick heaven ought to
reject this in front of thousands of
faces not thousands but hundreds of
cameras and video and witnesses it means
that he has absolutely no regard for
anyone else but his own agenda I mean it
takes a lot for you to refuse to shake
someone saying let's just start there
right it takes an absolute lot of gall
for you to refuse to shake someone's
hand in this type of setting but he did
that now conservatives are attacking
Fred Guttenberg saying that he
sandbagged him that he caught him off
guard that he was an unidentified man
and Dianne Feinstein had this to say
about it because she wanted to make sure
that the record was clear this is what
she said on Twitter she said quote I
invited Fred Guttenberg to sit in the
audience at today's hearing because the
Supreme Court affects the lives of real
people he knows firsthand how brick
Cavanaugh's extreme views on guns could
lead to more massacres Thank You Fred
for honoring your daughter
I mean so he obviously would not have
been there if he wasn't supposed to be
there but even if I mean how many people
approached you you are whether you want
to call it a Pollak call his position a
politician or not right now before you
get into your office as justice on the
Supreme Court
you are politicking and part of
politicking is shaking hands it is the
most fundamental most basic step in
politicking no he is not going to be an
elected of
official but he is not a just as yet in
right now he's campaigning in his own
way to convince America that he's the
best choice and this is what he does
with this opportunity now I want to play
a clip from Fred Guttenberg who
explained exactly why he did what he did
yesterday candidly
my hope to him was simply to say I hope
you change your stance I hope you look
in my eye I hope you see that this pin
that I wear on my lapel or these
bracelets that I wear that's all I have
to get close to my daughter now and I
hope you can be part of making sure no
other parent has to feel the way I do
because we can fix this and I'm
concerned that he won't be that person
but he's a father and I try I was hoping
to appeal to that and truth be told the
reality is that Brett Kavanaugh is being
funded his campaign to become the chana
the justice on the Supreme Court is
being pushed and promoted by the NRA so
you don't you there's not much room for
coincidences in this type of scenario a
man who has had millions of dollars
poured into his push to become a justice
on the Supreme Court by the NRA looked
at a father who was waging his own
battle against the NRA and decided that
he's not worth my time to shake his hand
listen it's small moments like these
that reveal to you the caliber of a
person the caliber of a man a caliber of
a leader of a potential leader and this
definitely this definitely demonstrates
that Brett Kavanaugh is is not the type
of person that we need on the Supreme
Court
let alone all of the issues right let's
let's be sure we knew this before this
photograph we knew that he's the wrong
person on abortion he's a wrong person
own on gun control
he's a wrong person on privacy he's a
wrong person on any litany he's
definitely the wrong person in terms of
constraining the powers of the the
presidency right he's he's literally
been picked so that he can give
President Trump all of the leeway he can
from the judiciary in this investigation
is happening with Bob mullet so so we
already knew that he was not the
a person that we needed in this country
but it's something and I pull up the
image on the screen one more time it's
something when you can capture all of
that in a single image